[Applause]
[Music]
taiwan has become something like the
Asian version of Asterix and Obelix is
irreducible village a small Enclave
surrounded by a great Empire that wants
to engulf it and as with the small
Gallic village the citizens of Taiwan
also have their own magic potion to
defend themselves against their enemies
of course in this case we aren't talking
about potions made by a druid we're
talking about the power of the United
States of America well the United States
and also recently well something else
folks Taiwan has a new ally a new secret
advantage that is already fueling
Beijing's wrath so listen up
[Music]
Beijing's wrath
now on is facing enormous pressure from
mainland China which as you know claims
the island as part of its territory and
we're not talking about the usual
international politics tug of war here
you know the usual you gather there can
you take it I get angry I threaten you
then we bolt omit ly let it be no that
is not the situation here at all
Beijing they've actually even set a
deadline
see the Chinese government has made it
clear time and time again that it's
ready to do what it takes and for the
year 2040 9 the centennial of the
People's Republic of China Taiwan will
have to rejoin mainland China of course
this leads to a problem and not exactly
a small one the Taiwanese they're not
really in favor of it in fact they want
nothing to do with it in fact as we
mentioned here on visual politic in 2016
the Democratic Progressive Party of
Syene Wang who by the way it was one of
our 2017 award-winning leaders of the
year and is something of an independent
gained power in Taiwan all the power
both of Congress and the presidency and
since then let's just say Beijing hasn't
taken it very well in fact that wouldn't
be accurate they took it horribly since
tying Wang became president practically
from the very first minute Beijing's
pressures against the island of
multiplied and in recent months it's
already reached politically obsessive
levels they've cut diplomatic ties tried
to punish Taiwan economically and have
implemented huge military exercises all
around the island
but that's not all cheating things
government is also using all its means
to erase Taiwan's name and identity from
the map for example when we published
our first video about Taiwan 20
countries formally recognized the
islands government in Taipei as China's
legitimate government yes as we've
covered before Taiwan has never declared
its independence but for years it's
claimed it's China's legitimate
government and of course diplomatically
our country can only have one recognized
government while Beijing has multiplied
its diplomatic agenda to end this
situation today just a year later only
17 countries consider it so and almost
all of them are tiny but that's not all
in fact given the circumstances
Beijing's move would be understandable
something like you're I'm the legitimate
government of China but this is no
longer a question of who's the
legitimate government but simply that
Beijing has said both actively and
passively that it will never allow
Taiwan to become independent and one way
to prevent that is precisely by trying
to erase all traces of the islands
national identity China essentially
wants be able to think Taiwan what's
that car brand you see in order to pull
this off Beijing is blocking the
presence of Taiwanese representatives
and even its journalists from all of the
international bodies that it can such as
the World Health Organization it's
finding companies that sell products in
China with the made in Taiwan label this
is something that has happened to the
Japanese Jain Mooji another case we'd
know about is that of the gap clothing
chain which had to apologize for selling
t-shirts in North America that didn't
include Taiwan as part of China even
Taiwanese music groups like the indie
punk band fire EXO you don't support the
reunification are disappearing from
Chinese streaming music services and how
about one more example well due to
Beijing's threats airlines from all over
the world and no longer using the
islands name yeah you really did hear
that right even American companies
aren't using Taiwan's name anymore I
mean yes you can absolutely book a
ticket from New York to Taipei but don't
ask which country you're going to
although yes unlike other international
companies such as British Airways or
bluffed hands up who are already selling
tickets to Taiwan as part of China
American companies have simply resorted
to the ghost country trick the ghost
country trick is then just selling
tickets to Taipei and when anyone asks
it's just a response of who cares how we
can't blame them
the Chinese aviation market is simply
too big and many companies have direct
interests in that country China's goal
regarding Taiwan has never changed that
goal is to swallow up Taiwan sovereignty
exterminate Taiwanese democracy and
achieve ultimate unification Li Tong way
Taiwan's first democratically elected
president to the new york times without
getting any further american airlines as
a shareholder of china Southern Airlines
and Delta on the other hands of China
Eastern Airlines however just a moment
here because it's not all bad news for
Taiwan along with the US is support the
island has gains another powerful ally
or you could say Taiwan is developing
its own magic potion no I'm not talking
about weapons listen up
the mecca of freedom
folks Taiwan has been chosen as the
first Asian host of the Oslo Freedom
Forum something like a congress and
international meeting on human rights
but some of you might be wondering a
Congress I mean is that really so
important well do viewer in fact it is
not so much for the Congress that
ultimately what it means
[Music]
even though global democracy has
experienced a general trend of
backsliding in the past few years
Taiwan's democracy has persisted and
continues to thrive Taiwan can continue
to serve as an inspiration to Democrats
in Asia including those in China
Keti Chen vice president of the Taiwan
Foundation for democracy you see for
decades Hong Kong was the great bastion
of freedom of expression in this area of
the world both international media and
human rights organizations established
their headquarters there and not only
that Hong Kong also became a refuge for
many political exiles like for example
the student leaders who led the
Tiananmen Square protests however in
recent times as we've seen here on
visual politic things have changed and
Beijing has tightened its grip on Hong
Kong's politics
[Music]
Hong Kong was originally the first
choice for the Asia Bureau but today
China doesn't just suppress its own
people
it is now increasingly exporting that
suppression to Hong Kong will Eric I see
an emeritus member of reporters without
borders and a student leader of the 1989
Tiananmen protests bus as this change
was taking place
Taiwan consolidated itself as a vibrant
democracy and one of the freest places
in the region that's precisely why it's
replacing Hong Kong as the mecca for
freedom activists and human rights in
Asia this is even though Taiwan until
1987 was under the control of an
ironclad dictatorship
[Music]
now for example one of the human rights
film festivals that used to be held in
Hong Kong has been moved to Taiwan Lam
Winkie one of the Hong Kong book
publishers who is kidnapped by the
Chinese government two years ago has
announced that he will reopen his book
store in Taiwan and Reporters Without
Borders announced in 2017 that its first
Asian office will be in Taipei freedom
of expression is a big part of Taiwanese
culture Cedric Alvie ani the Taipei
Bureau director of reporters without
borders these are just some examples of
what is already becoming a generalized
trend democracy political plurality
freedom of expression human rights
same-sex marriage Taiwan is becoming a
benchmark for all of them and obviously
this poses a huge problem for China's
interests for one the Taiwanese love
freedom so of course they don't want
anything to do with being ruled again by
Beijing and for another while the
Chinese government attempts to erase to
annihilator the Taiwanese identity
throughout the world the country has
suddenly emerged as a center of freedom
with all the influence that that entails
also it's much harder to consider
attacking a country that is famous for
its commitment to human rights the
international community simply would not
accept it and the truth is that this may
be Taiwan's best move listen up
the new move in mid-july 2018 the second
Apache helicopter squadron made in
Taiwan went into service it's part of
what is strengthening the partnership
between Washington and Taipei of which
incidentally we're going to speak about
in a future video among other things
this includes a significant increase in
the sale of equipment and military
technology to the island Taiwan is
buying helicopters tanks missiles
anti-aircraft systems and now even wants
to develop its own submarines however
despite all of this it seems
increasingly clear that militarily it'll
be difficult for Taiwan to stop China
the budget difference is simply
overwhelming China's military budget is
between 15 and 20 times that of Taiwan
and it shows
yes it's true nowadays there's the
United States umbrella but even that
isn't enough to have the guarantee that
the international community would act in
their favor Taiwan needs to reinforce
its influence in the world especially if
it wants to become an independent
country now the question we need to ask
ourselves here is how on earth are they
going to be able to achieve this
[Music]
well folks that may surprise you the
military strategy while essential may
not actually be the most important thing
here Taiwan has to gain influence and
prominence in the world while overcoming
the economic problems that we talked
about in a previous video to do so
pickin for example seek to attract
students from all over Asia and indeed
the world by giving them facilities
promoting programs in English and
attracting first-rate teachers that
would mean gaining a lot of influence
and of course human capital second
Taiwan can set in motion and aggressive
policy to attract multinationals and get
them to establish not only factories
here but above all research centers and
administrative headquarters they can do
so by devoting special attention to
attracting content creation companies
Media film studios youtubers etc etc
third the government could seek to
become a logistics Enclave for example
by developing its airport capabilities
and thus becoming a large communications
hub fourth it can attract more
professionals from the rest of Asia this
would allow it to both face the island's
aging population problem and also to
strengthen its ties with the workers
places of origin and fifth it must
continue to promote its role as a center
for human rights and freedom of
expression alright so maybe this plan is
not as exciting as just buying huge
weapons but it would certainly be
cheaper trying to meet with China only
via the military route seems complicated
and it would boost the island's economy
as well as give it a lot of influence
around the world given the circumstances
a university a film studio a hotel or
the headquarters of a human rights or
multinational organization can be much
more important for the island survival
than for example a battleship and no
this is not about giving some ultra
pacifist discourse or anything like that
it's just about pure pragmatism if we're
talking about guaranteeing Taiwan's
independence and freedom this is how to
do it
but now it's your turn do you think the
international community should guarantee
Taiwan's security well leave your answer
in the comments as well as in this
survey and I really hope you did enjoy
this video please do hit that like
button if you did and don't forget to
subscribe we've got brand new videos
every Monday and Thursday also do not
forget
check out our friends at the reconsider
media podcast they provided the vocals
in this episode that were not mine also
this channel is possible because of
patreon and our patrons on the platform
of patreon
one final P and that would be please
consider joining them and supporting our
mission of providing independent
political coverage and as always I'll
see you in the next video
[Music]